[Musique]
l'histoire mois selene j'ai 22 ans je
suis étudiante et je suis une femme
ordinaire
pourtant ça n'a pas empêché de partir à
l'aventuré seul
revenons un peu en arrière j'ai grandi à
la campagne
fait unique sur protégé par mes parents
d'une fille dit et maladive et sans
grande confiance en moi mais à l'âge de
19 ans je décide de partir seul en
écosse et en rentrant de ce premier
voyage j'ai trouvé l'inspiration et
l'énergie d'accomplir davantage grâce
aux rencontres set en chemin
en voyageant j'ai découvert que j'étais
capable de me débrouiller tout seul et
de parler à des inconnus alors que le
monde me semblait si dangereux en
voyageant je me suis senti à ma place
pourtant si loin de chez moi et sans
véritable repère un peu paradoxal non
mais alors comment moi qui étais si
timide et qui me perdais dans mon propre
quartier en arrivant à paris
si je devenue celle qui n'a peur de rien
et part sans réfléchir à la rencontre
donc une
alors chers amis voyageurs
je vous emmène pour un périple autour de
quelques histoires
après l'école j'ai visité quelques pays
en europe seul et je me suis dit qu'il
serait bon de d'élargir mes horizons de
repousser les frontières à la fois
géographique et mentale je voulais
partir au maroc
seul problème je suis une femme attendez
je répète je suis une femme parce que je
suis une femme tout le monde
ma famille mes amis aussi internet me
dit qu'il est bien trop dangereux de
partir seul il préférerait que j'ai un
bon copain bien costaud pour
m'accompagner et me protéger mais me
protéger de quoi alors je suis trop
curieuse et je décide de partir d'abord
pour angers
j'arrive à tanger méfiante vigilante
mais surtout impatiente et oui parce que
je suis une femme j'ai eu quelques
galères les mauvaises rencontres
mais ça n'a pas empêché cette expérience
d'être inoubliable c'était par exemple
ce marchand de tapis qui au coin d'une
rue m'invite à prendre le thé et avec
qui je discute pendant plusieurs heures
au maroc
je me rends à fès et à ce moment là j'ai
un plan une idée partir à la découverte
du sud pour ça j'ai besoin d'une voiture
et aussi deux compagnons de route parce
que je n'ai pas trop de moyens
à peine arrivé je rencontre daniel un
brésilien
drake un américain et il m un slovène
trois hommes trois hommes que je connais
depuis à peine 24 heures et pourtant je
sens que je peux leur faire confiance
pendant deux semaines nous partons à la
découverte du pays nous traversons les
montagnes enneigées de l'atlas
découvrons les plaines arides de la
région de ouarzazate et nous dormons
chez l'habitant mais aussi dans le
désert du sahara à la belle étoile
ça fait un peu rêver non et puis nous
finissons par gagner les montagnes de la
région d'in che des montagnes isolées où
nous rencontrons jeune berbère qui parle
anglais et propose de nous faire visiter
un petit peu et là nous croisons des
enfants qui jouent au foot dans la rue
le ballon passait en voisin celui ci
vient leur apporter et dès qu'ils voient
nos têtes d'étrangers ils nous proposent
de venir boire le thé chez lui alors on
accepte et il nous présente à sa famille
notamment à sa tante fatma fatma unis
mais revêt une dame âgée avec un visage
magnifique
arborant un tatouage d'herbert des yeux
dans noir profond une malicieuse assez
autour du thé fatma tante de mme
apprendre quelques mots de berbères et
elle me fait des blagues sur tout malgré
son grand âge elle n'a perdu ni sa
vivacité ni sa malice
c'est une jeune fille dans un corps de
vieilles dames et c'est à ce moment là
que je comprends tout l'intérêt du
voyage grâce à l'enchaînement de ces
hasards et de toutes ces petites
rencontres
je suis arrivé jusqu'à elle ce moment de
poésie et je suis surprise par
l'hospitalité de ces gens si
bienveillant qui partage de leurs pains
et de leur temps sans rien attendre en
retour
et ce malgré la barrière de la langue et
les différences culturelles
alors forte de cette première expérience
je décide que je repartirais bientôt une
cette fois je veux encore repousser mes
limites géographiques et surtout
maintenant l'inde la culture indienne
fascine depuis longtemps mis un grand
problème se pose encore une fois je
connais la mauvaise réputation du pays
si dangereux et en particulier pour les
femmes font entendre
tout le monde s'inquiète et moi je me
dis que ce sera un défi que je vais
prouver à tout le monde que c'est
possible et ce sera la promesse aussi
d'une vraie aventure en janvier 2018
me voilà dans l'avion j'arrive dans la
vie d'amritsar au nord de l'inde et du
pakistan
c'est un dépaysement total un choc de la
conduite effréné du chauffeur de taxi
jusqu'au vaches qui se balade
tranquillement dans la rue
alors oui
représente de clichés mais c'était
salindres pour moi et c'est un échec
je devais rester deux mois je ne passe
que quinze jours en inde parce que je
tombe malade
je suis épuisée et surtout les regards
des gens très curieux me rend vulnérable
dans la rue quand je me promène
l'inde est un échec parce qu'il n'y a
pas eu ces rencontres providentielles
qui font la beauté du voyage et tout son
intérêt
et puis dans mon roman j'ai compris que
le voyage était aussi une façon de se
mettre à l'épreuve
une façon de se découvrir un peu sonné
en rentrant à paris gélules usage du
monde de nicolas bouvier un grand
écrivain et voyageur suisse qui disait
un voyage se passe de motifs
il ne tarde pas à prouver la lune on
croit qu'on va faire un voyage mais
c'est le voyage qui vous fait et vous
des faits le voyage vous des faits c'est
une façon de réapprendre de désapprendre
des autres et de soi une façon de se
remettre en question et de se poser des
questions beaucoup de questions et je
comprends que à présent le voyage sera
tout à fait différent
mordu de l'asie je veux y retourner dès
que possible en avril cette année je me
rends au vietnam à peine arrivé dans les
rues de hanoï
thoune et quévert événements ce sont les
gens qui me saluent parfois au détour
d'une rue pour mature avec l'ensemble ou
devant l'agitation et puis le calme sous
dans des petites ruelles les marchés et
aussi cette petite fille qui mangeait
son bol de nouilles assise dans une
échoppe
avec sa belle petite boule un jour de
plus et si je suis au vietnam
c'est parce que j'ai un projet partir
explorer les montagnes du nord près de
la frontière avec la chine afin de
rencontrer les ethnies qui vivent là bas
et qu'ils ont une culture des cultures
vraiment riche et diverse
le seul problème c'est que pour faire
cela il faut conduire une je n'ai jamais
conduit deux motos de toute ma vie j'ai
à peine deux ans de permis voiture et je
cette idée folle mais un beau soir je
rencontre farid qui vient d'arriver dans
mon auberge de jeunesse 40 ans avec un
parcours assez atypique biker professeur
d'anglais et cuisinier farid me propose
de m'apprendre
mais pas n'importe quand ils me
réveillent à une heure du matin parce
qu'à ce moment là les rues de hanoi sont
désertes autrement
l'agitation est totale et c'est
dangereux alors j'accepte et je me lance
je suis nerveuse j'ai vraiment très peur
et puis en 48 à moi je sais conduire une
moto parce qu'il avait je décide de me
lancer sur ce circuit
je prends en bus j'arrive dans le meur
deep et je loue la moto 700 km de route
seul dans la montée vertigineuse et
défoncé mais j'avance à mon rythme
tout va bien je dors dans des villages
où les gens meurent soit vais surtout me
saoule joyeusement à l'alcool de riz et
il me force à chanter au karaoké aussi
et vit avec quelques mots deux
vietnamiens un peu d'anglais et beaucoup
de gestes surtout on tente de se
comprendre
créée on se comprend on partage des
instants de rire de joie en mangeant
bois et je comprends que ces sources
le voyage partagé toujours et encore et
cela pour moi n'a été possible que parce
que j'ai réussi à faire preuve d'audace
le voyage est une façon de se découvrir
plus audacieux plus libre et surtout
plus vivant alors une cherchons ni
voyageurs
laissez-moi besoin dans notre dernière
destination la thaïlande
alors oui je sais si beaucoup restent au
monde cet été je décide que je veux voir
ce que la thaïlande a à m'ouvrir car
c'est un pays très touristiques et je
veux m'éloigner des sentiers battus
alors toujours grâce à farid je peux de
nouveau loué une moto mais cette fois je
pars pour 900 kilomètres seul dans la
montagne
également dans une région au nord près
de la birmanie et les routes sont encore
plus effrayante et bien sûr mouillé
parce que c'est la mousson je conduis
sous la pluie une charmante expérience
et je fais ça parce que je veux
rencontrer les carènes les carènes sont
un peuple qui c'est un peuple qui vit
donc dans cette région qui a été forcé
de fuir la berme la birmanie par dont
tout l'est sont originales parce que ils
ont été persécutés par le gouvernement
et l'école les carènes sont aussi connus
parce que les femmes portent décoller
pour s'allonger le coup et il ya quelque
chose qui nous troublent les car elles
ont un statut de réfugié politique
mais ils sont aussi considérés en
quelque sorte comme une attraction
touristique
alors je veux comprendre et je me dis
qu'il est temps d'y aller de rencontrer
ces personnes
j'enfourche ma moto
je traverse les routes qui sont dans la
jungle je parcours des routes parfois
inondées j'ai bien failli me casser la
figure plusieurs fois je vous avoue et
puis il y avait beaucoup de boue aussi
j'étais tout le temps en salle et puis
je fini par arriver dans ce village où
je rencontre new miu miu miu c'est une
jeune femme de 19 ans pas timide du tout
avec qui j'échange sur sa culture mais
aussi sur ses projets ses passions et sa
famille finit par me proposait de passer
la nuit chez eux dans leur petit village
au milieu de la jungle et ça peut
paraître exotique
j'ai dit que c'est juste une belle
opportunité de rencontrer des gens qui
vit un peu différemment demain avec nous
nous préparons dîner et nous parlons
encore et encore nos jours de la guitare
ans apprend des choses et puis je me
demande je réfléchis lumio un toit de
quoi manger
l'électricité entre 20h le soir et 5h le
matin elle va à l'école encore ceux des
cours mais la situation de sa communauté
est très précaire
et dire que je suis venu du si loin
alors que noël est confiné dans un petit
périmètre
parce que elle n'a pas de papiers taille
parce que la situation est encore très
complexes
en effet elle doit rester dans cette
région de son pouvoir sortir et le
tourisme lui semble être une seule la
seule fenêtre vers le monde extérieur
alors moi je dois repartir le coeur
lourd et je me dis que le voyage en
thaïlande prend sens dans ces lieux
perdus
loin de la foule ses excès et de ses
mots une chers amis voyageurs notre
périple s'arrête ici est rudement bien
une chose si c'est des liens si fragile
souhaité tenter de comprendre des
réalités différentes de la scène
et ce sans cesse se remettre en question
voilà les sens véritable du voyage samoa
et être une femme n'empêche pas de
voyager ça n'empêche pas de réaliser ses
rêves
bien au contraire j'ai rencontré de
nombreuses fans sur ma route qui
partagent des histoires encore plus
surprenante est incroyable que les
miennes des femmes qui hier son parti ex
pour un autre monde qui en ce moment
même où je vous parle sont en train de
le parcourir et qui demain partir de ce
sera peut-être vous et puis je me
souviens encore de ma mère qui me disait
n'y voyons et là tu n'a que 20 ans tu
aimes tu vas tout le temps de voyager
aujourd'hui j'en ai 22 et je suis bien
contente de ne pas l'avoir écouté trop
têtu alors soyez têtu si vous avez
l'opportunité de partir saisissez cette
chance parce que voyager a été la
meilleure décision que j'ai prise
jusqu'ici
alors quand on trévoux les aventures
merci
[Applaudissements]